as asset prices continue to fall
everyone keeps asking the same question
is this the bottom or do we got more to
go some people want to know when the
bleeding will stop and other people are
sitting there licking their chops saying
i got cash and i want to know when to
deploy it now the real secret is that no
one knows where the bottom really is and
some people would even argue it's not
important to get the absolute bottom but
of course there's plenty of strategists
plenty of people who analyze the market
in various data points and they go ahead
and they try to inform you as to where
the bottom of the market may be one of
those individuals liz young over at sofi
she had a great tweet this morning in
which she stated only 16 of nasdaq
stocks are trading above their 200-day
moving average getting close to levels
of prior market bottoms 2002 2009 2018
and 2020. she still won't call the
bottom but if you like watching these
indicators here we are and so of course
that's exactly what you should be doing
with data it doesn't tell you exactly
where the bottom is it doesn't tell you
exactly when you should deploy fresh
capital or when the bleeding will stop
but you can use this metric and many
others to keep an informed mind trying
to time the bottom of markets is as dumb
as trying to time the top of markets at
the end of the day the people who
perform the best usually tend to be the
people who buy great assets they dollar
costs averaging them and they hold them
forever just as warren buffett said our
favorite holding time is forever and
that tends to be not only a better
investment strategy but it's also easier
on your mental health it's easier in
terms of peace of mind stop trying to
time market stop trying to pretend
you're a day trader stop trying to sit
on every single piece of news
and simply say to yourself if i like an
asset and i loved it at a higher price
and now it's at a lower price and i'm
just going to continue to dollar cost
average then i don't need to change
anything ultimately i'm just picking up
more of that same asset at a lower price
that's true of stocks real estate
commodities crypto and almost any other
financial market in the world at the end
of the day the people who have the long
time horizon they don't freak out
they're not for sellers they don't worry
about day-to-day price movements chill
out life is good
assets aren't going anywhere they can't
go down forever and at the end of the
day if you understand what good assets
are and you hold them for that long time
period
this it's just a blip on the radar that
you might literally just laugh at later
that's the whole way investing works and
that is why being informed is important
but stop trying to day trade you ain't a
day trader and just as liz pointed out
it's no ability to call the absolute
bottom
there's a lot of signals that are saying
pay attention we may be close hey you
did you like this video great we make
five of them a day and post them here on
this channel make sure you subscribe
like the video and see you next time